because my my exposure to anime has got
like now that I think back to it there's
there's the main phases of like the
Pokemon phase and then there's the
Toonami phase well I'd see it on Toonami
and TV then there was this huge gap I
the exact same yeah yeah and then I did
like I realized now that in this huge
gap I still had like small exposures to
anime like whenever I go to Thailand
we'd always have these shitty shitty
Thai dubs like that like Ultraman was
was like a massive in Thailand you never
know that's even though that's not an
anime but we have like Dragon Ball Z
dubs and man having listening to Thai
doves they've already got five voice
actors and actresses and they voice
every character in every anime who's
growing up in Southeast Asia
knows what I'm talking about when you
have five voice actors who plays every
character in every show and then my
cousin showed me I think was Princess
Mononoke just oh well since it came out
I didn't know it was animated just like
was this animated film I thought it was
Disney how old are you and you watched
Princess Mononoke
ah and it came out in 97 yes I must have
been like like it was the year after
came out because his gruesome movie to
watch it yeah I thought I thought that
movie was just Disney and then just just
before I discovered like Naruto NeoAir
that I went through the LimeWire phase
just for music though I didn't know no
just just for music same here right so I
would be browsing browsing LimeWire for
me I got probably you'd like downloading
Linkin Park or Papa Roach or something
like that as you do 2004 and then
something else likes you know sometimes
you download a file yeah and it's not
the file you aim for likes it's what you
mean every file the Bill Clinton fire so
in LimeWire someone was just circulating
bible black clips
yeah the dog
I never knew that Bible Black was a
Japanese anime because I'm just like
what is this shitty poem that I'm
watching how's the kid how's the kid I'm
like it's kind of hot though this is
[ __ ] amazing
that's exactly how Aki discovered it
yeah she said in multiple videos that
like going through lime while obviously
looking for the new Lincoln Park just
trust people and it was the tentacle
scene of bible black and she's like this
is like she had like an epiphany she was
like this is the most amazing thing ever
like because that I don't even remember
I don't want to get onto the top people
I don't remember how I discovered people
I killed the top because because I
didn't I obviously didn't know it was
hentai I didn't even know it was anime
holy [ __ ] I'm having a [ __ ] epiphany
now I will black wasn't the only hand
side downloaded on there oh my god like
I like cuz I remember I remember
downloading full length and and uh no
hentai that came out in the 90s I can't
remember the name but I got why why are
you downloading full length and tag
because I like like I say you just
downloading random files okay and I got
one of these files that are downloaded
was this hence I that I come home the
title had angel in the name there's
there's a lot of 19 yeah yeah yeah angel
the name I'm like what if I just what if
I just put this title into LimeWire and
see what comes up and they were like six
titles that came up so I can I'm like
I'm tired all I'm done writing all of
this how to destroy your laptop speedrun
did you ruin any laptops or pcs oh [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah I blamed it on my brother
and he totally got blamed for it but it
was totally me I couldn't blame it on
anyone cuz I'm the oldest